NOW THAT PAUL MANAFORT IS IN
JAIL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MARK STEYN IS AN AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
I LOVE THE IDEA OF A PERMANENT
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL WHO
INVESTIGATES EVERYBODY IN POWER
AND WHY STOP WITH LAWMAKERS?
WHEN I GET INTO THE GUYS WHO RUN
GOOGLE AND FACEBOOK?
SOMEONE WHO ISN'T ENCUMBERED BY
THE CORRUPTION OF THE DOJ?
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT?
>> THERE IS MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AND THERE'S
LAWS AGAINST EVERYTHING AND IF
YOU HAPPEN TO BE THE GUY THAT
THEY DECIDE TO LOOK INTO, THEY
CAN FIND SOMETHING OR THEY CAN
TURN YOUR ASSOCIATES OR IN THIS
CASE, THEY CAN PUT THE SQUEEZE
ON YOUR LAWYER.
I DON'T CARE WITH THE
CONGRESSMAN SAYS, I FIND WHAT
HAPPENS WITH MICHAEL COHEN
REPULSIVE.
LAWYER CLIENTS OR PRIVILEGE IT
IS SO BIG THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
BY ELIZABETHAN TIMES.
THE IDEA THAT YOU KICK THE GUYS
DOOR DOWN AND YOU TAKE
EVERYTHING AND WERE SUPPOSED TO
BE REASSURED BECAUSE THE
PROSECUTOR'S COLLEAGUE WHO IS
NOT WORKING ON THE CASE WILL GO
THROUGH EVERYTHING AND DECIDE
WHAT IS OR ISN'T COVERED BY
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE IS
LUDICROUS.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE NOT FROM HIS
COUNTRY, SO YOU MAY NOT READ
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," BUT THEY
ASSURED US TWO DAYS AGO THAT IF
YOU ARE NOT GUILTY, YOU
SHOULDN'T WORRY ABOUT
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS NO CAUSE FOR
WORRY TO HOLD ONTO THAT SACRED
ANCIENT RIGHT IF HE ISN'T A
CRIMINAL.
>> I SAW THAT AND WHEN THE STORY
BEGAN, THE ANNOUNCED THAT HE WAS
BEING BRIEFED BY THREE PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THE INVESTIGATION.
WE'VE ALREADY GOT THREE PEOPLE
LEAKING TO "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
THERE'S NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT.
IF IT'S THIS OTHER GUY WHO GOES
THROUGH ALL THIS STUFF, HE'S NOT
GOING TO LEAK IT.
THE FEDERAL JUSTICE, I GET
ANNOYED BECAUSE THAT CONGRESSMAN
WAS -- A FEDERAL JUSTICE IS A
TOILET IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT OPERATES ON BLACKMAIL.
MICHAEL COHEN KNOWS THAT THEY
HAVE A 97% CONVICTION RATE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE SOVIET
LEVEL.
IS IT REALLY THAT HIGH?
>> YES, SO THESE GUYS SAY WE
LEAN ON HIM.
THERE ARE SUPPOSEDLY AT MICHAEL
COHEN BECAUSE HE IS A NEW YORK
TAXI MEDALLION BUSINESS.
YOU'RE NOT TELLING ME THAT HE
DOCUMENTS FROM A DECADE AGO AND
WAS SHREDDING THEM ON THE 37TH
FLOOR OF THE COMFORT AND OR
WHEREVER HE WAS IN THERE SAYING
HE'S CORRUPT AND THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR REPLACEMENT.
I WILL GLADLY VOLUNTEER BECAUSE
I THINK THIS IS A DISGRACE AND
AT THE SAME TIME WHILE I'M
GETTING ANNOYED, THE FBI WON'T
HAND OVER THE COMMUNICATION TO
CONGRESS THAT STARTED ALL THIS.
NOW THEY NEED A FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR WHO CAN SEIZE
EVERYTHING HE WANTS FROM HIS
SUBJECTS LAWYER IN THE FBI WHO
WORKS FOR YOU IN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WON'T EVEN HANDLE THE
UNREDACTED DOCUMENTS THAT
STARTED THIS.
FEDERAL JUSTICE IS CORRUPT AND
NEEDS SOMEONE SERIOUS CLEANING
IT UP AND IF JEFF SESSIONS WON'T
DO IT, HE SHOULD GET OUT OF THE
WAY AND MAKE WAY FOR SOMEONE WHO
WOULD.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW WHY HE
NEEDS A LAWYER IF HE'S INNOCENT
OR WHY ANY OF US DOES.
>> THAT'S TRUE.